[Music]
welcome back so in the last lecture we
showed that you can solve linear systems
of equation ax equal to B even when the
a matrix is not square
so in this underdetermined or
overdetermined case where you have
either infinitely many solutions or no
exact solutions you can still find kind
of an optimal X using this more penrose
pseudoinverse which is based on the
singular value decomposition now in the
underdetermined case where there are
infinitely many solutions we this is
actually a solution if you multiply a by
this X tilde you actually get B and this
is the minimum to norm X that satisfies
this equation but in the over determined
case there are no exact solutions and
this will only approximately multiplied
by a to equal B so I wanted to walk you
through what that looks like and kind of
show you where the error crops up in the
in the over determined case of this
least square solution where we don't
expect to find an exact solution of our
equations so what we're gonna do is
we're actually going to take this
expression for X tilde and we're going
to plug it back into ax equals B so
we're gonna take a X and we're gonna say
X tilde now a is equal to u Sigma V
transpose and X tilde is V Sigma inverse
u transpose B okay now it looks like
this might actually all cancel out
because you know there's a lot of VV
transpose ax x' and Sigma's this is
definitely the identity Sigma Sigma
inverse is also the identity but here's
where we get stuck u times u transpose
at least if we're using the economy SVD
where these are kind of just the first
few M columns or a truncated SVD where
these are the first few columns of U
then in that case uu transpose is not
the identity matrix and it might not
even be that close to the identity
matrix so this equals u u transpose
be and I'm gonna be very explicit I'm
going to re-add my hats here this is the
economy SVD or a truncated SVD and so
these are quantities this u u transpose
is not the identity if it was then this
would equal B but because this is not
the identity this does not equal B and
that's why this is not exactly solved ok
so here's where it gets interesting uu
transpose B is the projection this is
the projection of B onto the subspace
spanned by the columns of U onto
essentially the span of the columns of U
now these columns of you also span the
matrix a so this is equal to the span of
the columns of the matrix a and this
makes a lot of sense because if I'm
going to have if I'm gonna find an X
that solves a system of equations ax
equals B the only way I can do that is
if B is in the column space of a if it's
in the span of the column space of a
because basically all that I can do when
I multiply a times a vector X is I take
linear combinations of the columns of a
that's what a times X does so this first
element of X is x that first column of a
the second element of X gets multiplied
by the second column of a and so on and
those all get added up and we're trying
to find some combination that equals B
so this B will only have a solution X if
B lives in the span of the columns of a
ok makes sense and here if I unless I
pick a really bad a this will actually
be over complete and the columns will
like there's more than enough columns
and a to span all of our n and so it's
high it's highly likely that B will be
in that span of a in this
underdetermined case now that's not true
in this overdetermined case unless B is
specifically chosen to be in the columns
face of a which it might be I might
choose B to be a linear combination of a
in which case there would be an exact
solution but if I just pick a random B
it'll almost certainly have some
component that is not spanned by the
vectors in a and so the best we can
possibly do the best least squared
solution X tilde is taking B and
projecting it onto the column space of a
because that's the best I'm ever gonna
do with ax in approximating B is
approximating the component of B that's
spanned by the columns of a and that's
exactly what this is saying so all of
the error crops up because this is an
orthogonal projection of B onto the
columns of U my singular vectors which
are also the same as spanning the
columns of a of the data matrix okay so
I think that's a pretty interesting
interpretation of this pseudo inverse
and understanding how error crops up in
the next lecture I'm going to show you a
little bit more mathematically exactly
what the conditions are where these
matrices do and do not have solutions
just just for completeness because I
think it'll be useful all right thank
you